Sierra Vista is the
location of our campus
here where we
started this program.
One third of [? CyberCom ?] is
on Fort Huachuca, about five
miles from us right now.
The network command is a
large defensive component
of cyber command
for the US military.
So we do have folks there.
But we also have
a pool of people
where we can draw from here.
So [? Cyberopolis ?]
is our virtual city.
We have about 15,000 virtual
personas, 15,000 residents that
are completely run by software.
So we have water
companies, power companies,
online news media.
We have large retailers,
banks, hospitals.
We have small retailers.
We have our own Facebook
called Social Park.
We have our own Twitter
called Chirpy Hub.
And every one of those
are used specifically
either to teach a concept,
or to practice on a concept,
or to test on a concept.
And that class and its
learning objectives
are tied back to the specific
knowledge units from NSA.
I have students in Afghanistan.
I have students in
Djibouti, Africa.
I have students all over
Europe, all over Canada,
in South America, and
in the United States.
The way we deliver
our content online
is live lectures
with hands-on labs,
and the ability to bring
all of those students
together regardless
of where they
are and still interact with
the professor synchronously
as they need to so they can get
that true face-to-face quality
of education with the
same learning environment
even though they're
remoting in online.